Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a comedy film called
“Sixty Million Dollar Man.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
Sing is a spoiled rich youngster living in Hawaii.
He has a dozen servants who bring him breakfast in
bed, help him take shower, and dress him up every
day. His life is unlike anyone else’s as he has a
very peculiar way of doing normal things; for
instance, he only gargles with fresh cow milk,
only takes a bath in his swimming pool with a
bunch of women, and only travels in a helicopter.
Tat is Sing’s personal assistant who manages
everything in Sing’s life. Because Sing has always
gotten everything he wanted, he has developed
a hobby of troubling everyone around him.
One morning, Tat and Sing board a helicopter to
fly to Sing’s college. All the students in the
college know him as the spoiled brat who plays
silly pranks. Still, because of his father’s
influence, no one dares to go against him. Sing’s
usual target is the school loner named Siu-Fu.
He breaks the toilet’s wall when Siu-Fu is
inside it to humiliate him in front of everyone.
The poor guy bawls his eyes out and runs away
naked and embarrassed. As Sing and Tat laugh at
yet another successful prank, they are approached
by a new girl named Chung-Chung. Initially,
she startles Sing because of her ugliness.
He is furious that she got admitted to their
college because he had especially told the
principal to only take in beautiful girls
with nicer bodies. Chung-Chung reveals that she
is the daughter of the science teacher, Professor
Chang. Unlike the others, she isn’t scared of
Sing and his influence. She calls him out for
the stupid prank, much to Sing’s annoyance.
Later, during Professor Chang’s class,
Sing arrives late as usual. The other students
give him space and move further away, except
for Chung-Chung who stays put. The professor
overlooks Sing’s ignorant behavior and continues
teaching. He talks about a new technology that
will allow people to be turned into cyborgs.
When he dissects a dead body to show them the
visual representation of the theory, the students
can hardly keep themselves from passing out.
During the lunch break, Sing and Tat come to the
cafeteria and everyone else walks away, afraid
of him. Again, Chung-Chung is the only one who
sits right beside him and continues eating. Sing
threatens to get her fired but Professor Chang,
who is nearby, says that it won’t be possible.
The professor also calls him the most disgusting
student he has ever had. If it weren’t for
his father being the director of the college,
Sing would have been beaten to death by the
people he troubles on the daily. To test if
his classmates would really do something like
that, he blurts out that his father is not the
director of the school. When the other students
hear this, they do not waste their time before
piling on top of Sing and beating him up.
Sing is left furious after the incident.
He and Tat break into the professor’s house at
night to teach him a lesson. They set up bear
traps in the basement lab, hoping that the
professor will fall right into it. But then,
as they are about to leave, Tat notices a
cut-off hand walking on its own. Initially,
Sing thinks Tat is joking and asks him to focus.
Seconds later, a pair of eyes stares at them,
startling the two. They struggle to get a hold of
the hand but it runs away into a corner. On trying
to pull it out, Sing comes across a half-human
body. The duo thinks they are being haunted by a
ghost and runs away. On his way out, Tat falls
into the beartrap and hurts his behind.
A while later, they call the police, suspecting
that the professor is conducting experiments by
dissecting people’s body parts. The police search
everywhere but cannot find the said pair of eyes
or the hand. They think the idea is absurd and
accuse Sing of wasting their time. In the end,
they evacuate Tat and Sing out of the house.
After everyone leaves, the hand and eyes appear
behind the professor, revealing that they
are in fact one of his cyborg experiments.
The following day, Sing is paranoid that the
professor will send the body parts to trouble
him again. Hence, he dresses up in football gear,
ready to defend himself in case anyone tries to
harm him. Sing’s father arrives from China to
give him a surprise but is beaten up by his
son after being mistaken for an intruder.
Following that, someone knocks on their front
door. On checking, Sing finds a seductive woman
named Bonnie, asking him to help her bathe.
It turns out that she is a neighbor who has been
watching him for a long time. Sing doesn’t miss
the chance to take her to his personal swimming
pool where the two clean each other. That night,
they go to a club and drink a lot. As they are
dancing, Bonnie sees her husband enter the club.
She reveals that her husband is a local crime
lord named Fumito. The couple tries their best
to hide but the organizer of a show announces
them the winner of a dancing competition.
When the spotlight falls on the couple,
they catch the entire club’s attention.
Fumito fumes in anger on seeing his wife
with someone else. He and his henchmen bring
the two to his house to teach them a lesson.
On reaching home, Sing passes out drunk. Bonnie
tries helping him but is knocked out when Sing
suddenly wakes up and hits her. He somehow gets to
his car and drives away while the gangsters follow
him. On reaching home, Sing is out of breath
and terrified. He tries to tell his mother what
happened, but she cuts him off, claiming that she
has something more important to say. She confesses
that she slept with Tat twenty years ago. This
means that the millionaire businessman Pai is
not actually Sing’s father, but his assistant
is. Pai overhears their conversation and calls
his wife a whore. Although he is relieved that
an ugly guy like Sing is not his biological son,
he is heartbroken by his wife’s betrayal.
Tat also joins the conversation and asks Sing
to stay as his son, now that everyone knows the
truth. However, Sing wants two million dollars and
is willing to continue being Pai’s son for money.
Tat is distressed because he has always loved
Sing as family. Sing, on the other hand, kicks
him out of the house to receive money from Pai.
He did what he had to in the heat of the moment
but the following day, Sing is guilt-ridden. He
always had Tat by his side growing up and after
knowing that he is his father, Sing cannot help
but feel sorry. Later that day, he goes to the
church for self-reflection and finds Chung-Chung.
He tells her what he did yesterday and how bad he
feels. Chung-Chung also begins to realize that
he is not as bad as she thought he was.
That evening, the gangster Fumito sends his
right-hand man Mark to kill Sing. They get into a
chase around the house when suddenly the lights go
off. When they turn back on, we see that Tat has
come to save his son. He puts his life in danger
for Sing but the two are caught in the end. Then,
their hands are cuffed together in a bathroom
stall, where Mark has planted a bomb. After the
gangsters leave, the father and son only have a
few seconds before the explosive goes off. Sing
takes responsibility for the first time and cuts
his arm off so Tat can escape. In the following
explosion, Tat survives but Sing passes away.
The next day Sing’s case is brought to professor
Chang. He reveals that although Sing
technically died in the explosion,
his lips remained unharmed. Using the technology
he has recently been developing, he can reform
Sing’s body with artificial parts, keeping only
his lips intact. Tatt speaks to his son’s lips
and assures him that he will be fine. However,
the cost of surgery is sixty million dollars.
Pai calls Sing and asks him to get rid of Tat if
he wants the money for surgery. But Sing has come
to his senses, even though he is only a pair of
lips. He renounces his rich father and decides to
stay dead not wanting to abandon Tat again.
Tat begs the professor to perform the surgery
using the six thousand dollars that he has. Chang
feels bad for the desperate father and agrees to
perform the procedure. But, the results won’t be
as good, as he will have to makeshift the body
parts with whatever things he has. Following that,
the professor spends days and nights aggressively
pinching and pushing the body. For the first
few tries, many things go wrong. Sometimes,
Sing wakes up with a square head, sometimes,
with a tiny hand, and the other times with hands
attached to his lower body instead of legs.
Then, a few weeks later, everything works out and
Sing is turned back to his older self with
makeshift body parts. Since he is now a cyborg,
his body runs on a battery that can die at any
time. Sing has to be careful with his life but he
is overjoyed to finally be back alive. While the
professor could find an alternative for all of his
body parts, finding a male genital was impossible.
Hence, currently, Sing has a faucet that helps him
pee. In the following scene, a funeral is held for
Sing so the gangsters won’t look for him again.
No one comes to the funeral except for
Chung-Chung who is genuinely sad about his death.
Sing sees her from afar and is happy
that at least someone cares about him.
Cut to two years later. Sing currently lives with
his father and has been looking for a job. He eats
batteries for every meal and has changed his
genitals to a shower head instead of a faucet.
One day, his college classmate Siu-Fu offers
him a job as a teacher in a school.
Sing is overjoyed that he finally gets to earn
money for himself but little does he know, he is
about to face the worst students in the country.
On his first day at work, he is instantly attacked
with buckets full of water and paintballs.
His fellow teacher saves him from the attack
and brings him to a safer place. He reveals that
fifty percent of the teachers who have come to
teach these students have resigned in only a day.
The rest have either turned into handicaps, died,
or gone crazy. With a renewed motivation to be
the most strict teacher possible, Sing enters a
classroom. He shows the students a knife to assert
his dominance but the youngsters trap him in a net
and throw their bags at him. The principal of the
school doesn’t care because the students are the
children of power and wealthy businessmen.
By the end of the day, Sing is heavily beaten
up and crucified to the school’s gate with
his showerhead hanging out. All of a sudden,
Chung-Chung appears and recognizes him. She has
turned into a beautiful and confident girl, in
contrast to how she was before. She tries to help
but Sing smugly claims that he can do it himself.
Moments later, she gets into a sports car
with her rich boyfriend and drives away,
much to Sing’s disappointment.
That night at home, Sing has lost all
hopes. When he is about to give up on life, the
professor comes to meet him and discloses that
he has invented a chip that will turn Sing into
a superhero. Basically, with the help of the said
chip, he will be able to transform into anything.
Sing is skeptical but he trusts the professor
with his body. After the chip is implanted,
Sing thinks of turning it into a rice cooker,
and to his surprise, he does. Then he turns into
a toothpaste tube and spends the rest of the night
like that. Now that he has superhuman powers, Sing
goes to impress Chung-Chung with it. He finds her
at a restaurant having dinner with her boyfriend
and his parents. When she excuses herself and
goes to the bathroom, Sing follows her behind.
He claims to be a changed person and begs her to
be his girlfriend. To showcase his skills,
he even transforms into a strange toilet.
When Chung-Chung is still not impressed, he takes
over a magic show happening in the restaurant
and shows his powers to the audience. By the
end of the night, he is flying in the sky with
Chung-Chung using an umbrella as a parachute.
An impressed Chung-Chung agrees to date him.
The next day, Sing goes to the school
confidently. He transforms his hand
into a water hose and teaches the students a
lesson for messing with him. Eventually, they
start to obey him and turn into good students.
Everything goes well in Sing’s life until one day
the gangster Mark finds out he is still alive
and attacks him. They get into a fight but Sing
defeats him easily with his new powers.
Mark’s boss Fumito is not someone who gives up
easily. He turns Mark into a cyborg as well. But
he budgets the surgery with sixty million dollars
and makes him even better than Sing.
A few days later, Sing and Chung-Chung are
getting married. Siu-Fu comes to the wedding but
Sing recognizes him as Mark in disguise. The party
is interrupted as the two get into a fight. Mark
terrorizes everyone and starts firing randomly.
Amidst the chaos, he fires a special weapon
at Sing that kills him instantly. Everyone
is in shock until Sing revives from his burnt
dead body resembling an old woman in a robe.
The professor discloses that the chip turns Sing’s
revenge mode on when he is defeated. Which means
that he is now more powerful than ever.
Sing transforms into a giant steam iron and
flattens his opponent. Following that, he
turns into a microwave and traps Mark inside.
The professor starts the microwave from outside
which melts Mark and finally kills him. In the
last scene, we see the professor hitting
on Sing because of his appearance as an old
woman. Chung-Chung playfully asks her father
to back off because he is marrying Sing.
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on the notification,
and leave a like to help the channel out.
Thanks for watching.